the raiders preparing for the dolphins
with the afc special team player of the
week place kicker daniel carlson made
all four of his field goal attempts
against the steelers john treach
introduces us to the raider with the
rocket leg
some may say he's just a kicker but not
the ravens or steelers or the footballs
flying from 50.
it's definitely a very different
position out there you know we're kind
of almost like golfers out on a football
field you know it's it's more of a
mental sport for us a lot of times than
it is physical
and so you know for me that's something
where experience is definitely paid off
the 26 year old from colorado is in rare
air when it comes to accuracy carlson
has made 29 of his last 31 field goal
attempts no one is happier to give
oakland's infield dirt the boot you know
oakland was obviously a really cool
experience to you know kind of close out
that chapter and you know play on that
baseball field for you know
get to experience that but as a kicker
and i'm sure many other positions
definitely like the perfect grass that
we have the reigning afc special teams
player of the week is a weapon
dangerous in reality and well i actually
played against myself in fantasy this
week in my own like friend group fantasy
and so that was tough because i took a
loss
and i definitely
definitely contributed to that reporting
from las vegas john treach